ladies and gentlemen welcome to
predatory marketing 101 today
we're talking about grant cardone and
damon john
you guys know him he's the undercover
billionaire guy
shark tank over here and they are saying
something disgusting that i want to talk
about i've been saying how the self-help
industry has really
gone south for a long time but this
illustrates my point better than i ever
could
and it also proves something uh which i
want to talk about right now which is
that people are saying that grant
cardone's
changed in my last video about grant
cardone they're saying keith three three
to five years ago he was legit that he
pushed
more into real estate i missed the old
grant right oh really well this is him
from 2017 so three years ago back when
he was
legit what was he saying then yeah
you're down a guy's
sitting there right now watching this
thing i got my last grand dude i got
christmas coming
should you spend it on this absolutely
what
these guys these little sharks are
selling and it's appropriate word
because they will eat you alive if they
if you let them they're selling a
thousand dollar product
that gets you damond on demand rise and
grind by
damon john and a 10x growth con ticket
and they're saying if you have a
thousand dollars left your name
bankrupt yourself to buy this product
now
i'm gonna of course tell you the obvious
which is that is
insane advice look at these guys they
will sell
anything they don't care who you are how
broke you are
all they care about is the numbers i've
been saying this you guys say hey it's
just a few bad apples in the industry
this is the industry where do you guys
think i get this stuff from
grant cardone he's like one of the
biggest in this industry damon john
massive in this industry why are you
guys pretending it's not the mainstream
of this industry pushing this narrative
the sooner people call this out
the better the software today is 9.97
grantcardone.com
this is disgusting sports like a shark
a guy's sitting there right now watching
this and i got my last grand dude and i
got christmas coming
should you spend it on this absolutely
i'll tell you the same thing
this is unethical and it's gross tell
you why
because go ahead damon the minute you
learn this and you then go out and get a
trademark instead of a patent that now
saved you
20 thousand dollars look at this
reach olympian level mind tricks
this guy literally just said well yeah
you're broke right you have a thousand
dollars
left to your name you buy this why is it
going to be worth it well because when
you go to get a patent versus a
trademark you're going to save twenty
thousand dollars
hey damon earth today people who have a
thousand dollars left
aren't worried about a trademark versus
a patent you
buffoon they're worried about putting
bread on their table i know it's
a foreign concept to rich people like
you you guys love to flex your wealth
but poor people don't have this luxury
what disgusts me
about this industry is how they have no
conception
of people you should not sell to do you
guys realize that if you sell get rich
products they will
always be sold anybody poor is gonna
want to buy that product
right because it's like selling a cure
for cancer ah this magic bean has the
cure for cancer last a thousand dollars
of course you're gonna buy that magic
bean for cancer same thing
with get rich courses which is why the
way to be ethical in this industry is
if first of all why would you have a
thousand dollar product but okay if you
do want a thousand dollar product
make it a premium product for people who
are in the price range right
qualify your prospect don't just say if
you have a
thousand dollars left it's relevant it's
not
they have bigger problems and how dare
you guys
pitch this how dare you or the minute
you realize
you weren't necessarily ready for
distribution you had to put a couple of
things in
but of course they're not ready for
distribution they have a thousand
dollars left your name now i want to
point one final thing out which is a
good thing to know
there's two versions of this talk the
exact same talk
there's the one that grant cardone has
on his youtube channel and there's the
one that was re-uploaded by this guy
right after the video what's interesting
what i found to be
very interesting is that there's a
slight difference
between these two uh videos i don't know
if you know that
like something was cut out of this video
cut out of
grant's video let's check out and see
what it is
a guy's sitting there right now watching
this and i'm i got my last grin
should he spin it on this oh actually
did you notice there's a
little cut there from here to here
look at this cut what could he possibly
have cut out
from this video what could he feel like
he didn't want people to see
sitting there right now watching this
and i'm i got my last grand dude and i
got christmas coming
oh sitting there right now watching this
and i got my last grand
should he spend it on this looks like he
cut out the part where he said
and he's got christmas coming up i was
wrong guys maybe these guys do have a
conscience they felt bad about the part
where they say and he has christmas
coming up they said nah
that's a little too predatory but the
part where we tell a guy with
a thousand dollars left to spend his
money on our course
that's fine but the part about christmas
let's let's clip that out that's not
such a good look for us
and people wonder why i rail against
this industry
obviously guys i look is it everybody in
this industry that's bad
no look sometimes i'm a little
hyperbolic it's not the whole industry
of course not
why i get so intense is because it is
the people at the top it is the grant
cardones
that i'm talking about guys you know
like if it were your small fries doing
some you know shady things okay i get it
every industry has a few bad apples like
we call it but this industry the
self-help industry
it's the people at the top that are the
bad apples i don't make
you look bad people say coffees oh
coffeezilla's always hating on us i
don't make you guys look bad
grant cardone is making you look bad
damon john is making your industry look
predatory
not me i'm just the messenger baby i'm
just playing you back what they said
and i'm holding them to account and look
at this part dude and maybe the biggest
feat of irony they say this
right here you need to get something
it's about you you can't help anybody if
you can
we're not telling you to hurt people
though we're not telling you to be
predatory
we're not telling you to do anything of
that nature would you say that people
should sell
a growth con ticket what is that a
glorified concert with a bunch of
pitches
from grant's little team of little uh
pitchmen oh and then damond on demand
are you gonna tell them to
charge that to the someone's last a
thousand dollars try to sell somebody on
that would that be predatory
guys fix up your industry okay you
complain about me
all these all these gurus are like
coffeezilla such a hater
dude if this stuff wasn't here wouldn't
be talking so why don't you fix up your
own industry
and then we'll start talking about how
great this industry is this is three
years ago they were doing it as you saw
recently in the last video
grant cardones up to his old treks i
don't know how you guys keep giving
these people your money
if it were me i wouldn't look guys my
opinion
i wouldn't give these people my money
they want your last a thousand
they'd take old grand grands last a
thousand if they could you better
believe it
hey that's where we're gonna leave it
this is why this stuff has to stop
all right i'll see you guys next time i
know what you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee